soir
j'ai une question à vous poser c'est
tout bête pourquoi vous 7,2 on est on
est plus drôle à 2 parce qu'il y avait
une troisième personne mais on l'a
éliminée
le on l'a dévoré lui tiennent des deux
depuis drôle j'aurais tendance à dire
moi mais je serai pas objectif je sais
que je serai bien voir ça tient
l'ebit à lady di non je vois si vous
n'étiez pas ensemble avec quel comique
aimeriez vous travailler fois le petit
par exemple charles pasqua mais non non
non et non
et toi le plus gros enfin le plus musclé
willy que vous aurez plus de carrière
autre angle et noir et blanc ah oui moi
ça m'aurait plu
ouais c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on est
en stand by en noir et blanc c'est
peut-être chez pas oui sénégalais du
muet même ses arguments ils avaient
l'intention de faire ça et ça me
plaisait pas aux chaînes
non